advice for single men a woman's
perspective Pete thanks for joining I
appreciate you brother I'm in my mid-30s
divorce oh sorry actually before I
continue I should Enlighten my viewers
because it's always important to
understand the source and what they're
feeling when they provide this
information um when women dispense
advice or single men and they're
single they're doing it from the
perspective of the guys that they're
already attracted so they're not doing
it for the general benefit of the males
or for men in general they're doing it
for the benefit of the guys that she's
already attracted to so remember that
when I'm reading this and some of these
I'm going to agree with I'll be honest
with you I've gone through it it's
looking good
so she says I'm in my mid-30s divorced
and have been on the dating scene for
the last five years okay so she's been
out there for five years doing what
she's been doing now I'm not claiming
all women are perfect or that we don't
have our own to work on but this
post is strictly advice for the men
again this post is strictly advised for
the men that I am already attracted to
as a mid-30s divorced woman keep that in
mind especially the 30s plus singles
which singles to me is the dating pool
that she's dipping her toes into now
she's saying we've got our together
our careers are established homes are
secure and we're doing the work on
ourselves we we know that we're looking
we know what we're looking for in a
partner now let me just highlight this
real quick we've got our together
our careers are established home secure
she's basically describing herself as a
guy that she wants to be with okay keep
that in mind we've seen this on the
ladies nights podcast when we're talking
to the gals hey what do you bring to the
table you know what is it that you bring
to the relationship and it's always some
version of I've got my together my
job's great my home secure I have a nice
car you know my house is decorated
beautifully you know stuff like that so
this is this is the description that
she's given not I'm feminine and I know
how to cook I know how to enter a man's
frame and complement his life that's
careers jobs secure
home I'll go on I've seen some repeated
behaviors that can be so off-putting but
easily avoidable I just like to help
some fellas out again help out fellas
that she's already attracted to this is
not for the general male population this
is for the fellas that she's already
attracted to
first thing she says is Take the Lead
now I'm going to agree with this one she
says if you're going on a first date
make the effort and the initiative to
plan something the up to you in
quotations for those of you that are
listening or it's whatever whatever you
want to do is it going to make a girl
feel wanted or like she's worth the
effort little thought and a Serv this
goes such a long way I'm going to
translate that to you is she wants to
follow a leader she wants to look up to
a giant she can't do that if you can't
tell her what time the day date is where
you're going to meet even go to the
extent if you want if you want to be a
total Chad and say that black dress you
wore in picture number three on the
dating app yeah wear
that simple as that just take the lead
plan the date make sure you take care of
it next thing she says and I'm going to
agree with this as well please for the
love of God just pay for the first date
if your funds are limited choose
something easy a coffee a walk in the
park now we've seen women um I've done
videos on the entrepreneurs and cars
Channel
usually some Tik Tok or something that I
came across on Twitter that basically
say ladies you shouldn't accept dates
these things and a coffee date happens
to be one of them whereas we've got this
one over here telling guys a coffee date
is absolutely fine now the reason why
it's absolutely fine is because the way
she's writing this she's writing it in
such a way that she's trying to convince
the guys that she's already attracted to
to modify their behaviors to suit her so
again like I've said on the entrepreneur
of car Channel when I'm responding to
this nonsense women don't get a trip
without a coffee date if she digs your
Vibe if she likes you she will go on the
coffee date she will go for a walk in
the park as I've stated here you guys
unplugging and seeing the code in The
Matrix a dessert she offers as a
possible solution which we've seen these
lists before these 29 Point lists where
women will say is not
acceptable if your date is unimpressed
by that and take it as a sign that a
more high maintenance girl is simply not
the gal for you again if she's attracted
to you she will do a cough you or walk
in the park or dessert like I said
before take interest in your date ask
questions and stay engaged it goes both
ways but nothing is more off-putting
than a man who either talks about
himself the whole time or does not make
the effort to show he wants to know you
at a deeper level ask and listen I'm GNA
agree with that as well but here's the
thing it's from the perspective of
sizing her up okay I mean if you show up
on a date and you're yapping women are
very self-interested like I've always
said Sol syst they have difficulty
seeing past their own nose so they're
more concerned with what goes on in girl
world so let me talk you know the key
thing is you're going to know if she
digs your Vibe if she starts asking you
questions okay now the types of
questions that you ask that she's going
to ask will vary if it's more on the
beta Buck side of thing she's going to
be like what do you do for a living not
because she's interested in what you do
for a living but she's interested in how
much money what you do for a living
brings in you see what I'm saying she
starts asking things about you know what
did you like about Egypt or what did you
like about the Greek Islands when you
were there that's interesting that's
like she's kind of interested in you
what do you like to do with your spare
time she's interested in you but it's
important to use your ears and your
mouth in the ratio that you were given
them in you have two ears and one mouth
use them in that ratio pay attention to
what she's saying it's gonna help you
size her up it's gonna help you spot red
flags as I outline in my book so you
should be sitting there and asking her
questions questions like tell me about
your childhood oh yeah what school did
you go to what's your relationship with
your parents like you don't necessarily
want to say what's your relationship
with your parents like but you know what
was your dad like growing up sort of
thing that's that's a more interesting
question right that'll help you spot if
she's got Daddy Issues see what I'm
saying here right so asking a couple
questions is always a good
thing uh I am not going to give a
lecture on chivalry so here comes the
chivalry part and again this is from the
perspective of she's already attracted
to the men this is the advice that she's
looking for she's dispensing to the men
that she already wants to get with okay
uh but a couple of small things make a
big difference get out of your cart
sorry get out of your car to greet her
offer her food first if you're sharing
walk her to her Uber or door when she's
leaving it's such small things now this
is just standard being a gentleman sort
of thing like if you're meeting somebody
for the first time you should get up out
of your chair and greet them I'm not
really sure why you would be sitting in
your car to greet for the first time
that's bizarre but again it's it's out
of courtesy even if it's a a dude and
I'm being introduced in a business uh
interaction transaction anything like
that of course you're going to get out
of your car or stand up to shake the
other man and then look in his eyes
you're not shaking the other woman's
hand you can greet it however way you
feel most comfortable but greet you know
be a gentleman it's pretty
straightforward right um mental effort
you're considering intive again so far I
agree with first four this is where it's
going to start to change a little bit
though uh now if you've reached a stage
where she's coming over for the first
time please clean up I mean guys if
you're not cleaning your house you
should have a cleaning lady I'm just
gonna say it it's it's pretty
straightforward if you're not cleaning
your house get a cleaning lady they're
not that expensive um an average
probably 2,300 square foot house is
going to cost you 120 to 160 bucks uh
per visit it's worth it I don't like
cleaning it's it's not a good use of my
time I have ladies that come over that
do it they're fantastic uh brilliant
brilliant just trust me pay for exul um
so so the advice again so far I agree
with right I personally take it a sign
that not only you not clean but you
don't even care to appear clean for the
first time uh at your house this
especially goes for the bathroom clean
your toilet and wipe down your sinks I
do not want to see bowel stains and
grime I laugh at this because this is
funny because
if a chick's coming over to dude's house
and he's got skid marks going in his
toilet I can't imagine what's
going mind man I mean this is
simple
like the appearance of friendliness I
you know women are attracted to that oh
man uh I continue to see this even with
men in their 40s and I don't understand
how anyone thinks that's acceptable you
know like I said you got skid marks in
your toilet hire a cleaning lady or
scrub them down
now we get into the hookup part now this
is where it gets interesting because
she's lecturing guys about becoming a
virtuous chivalrous masculine dude uh
that she wants to get with again she's
in her mid-30s she's been divorced and
in the dating scene for five years what
does that mean in the five years I don't
know she could have she could have ran
through the entire city block she could
have been in a couple of long-term
relationships who knows maybe we'll find
out in a second
uh shy so if you reach a stage where
she's coming over clean up bathroom okay
so now we're talking about the hookup
part why she talking about the hookup
part if she so if she's such a good
catch if you're about to hook up make
the effort to ensure you're clean and
fresh I get that we might get a little
musty sometimes even if we're generally
clean people take the time or excuse
yourself and check the pits good I don't
know why the pits would matter like is
she going to lick them or something
anyway she wants to know that your pits
are good if you don't if you don't even
if you can't even bother to take a
shower get yourself some wet WIP you
know some wet wipes some baby wipes or
whatever just give yourself a little
Spanish shower that's what they call it
you know back in the day the Spanish
shower
little clean enough right do something
basic like that
straightforward um must see sometimes if
we're generally clean uh or take the
time to excuse yourself it'sit okay are
you getting some real action wash your D
and get and really get in there boys
wash your D and really get in there
don't forget behind your
nuts now I don't know what the hell
she's doing behind your ball right
behind your nut there something called
the
ashole what is she doing down there I've
experience the most put together men end
up with a musty set of balls that I
won't go near if you take the risk of me
taking a hit on that then what else
don't you care about so quite a bit of
vulgar language for a G that's you know
on a dating app it's talking about
chivalry and asking questions and get to
know her all of a sudden now she's
talking about the alpha seed she's
talking about the
alpha okay this is where she's
going next one if you're expecting a
hookup or an overnight guest please have
clean sheets and a fresh
towel you hear her follows wants you
want the alpha but you got to have some
clean sheets and a fresh
towel it's so basic but Mak come off
like a real grownup see this is a
shaming tactic right uh shaming tactics
are a real put off guys don't ever don't
ever deal with them put your foot down
walk away nonsense H grown up you're
real grown up now that you changed your
sheets and giv her a fresh uh she says
she recently went on a couple of dates
with a 50-year old man so she's hooking
up with a guy older than her lovely guy
I was excited to spend the night he had
one that used smelly bath H that clearly
had not been watched in ages that was
enough for me to lose attract back in
excusable and representative of more it
says hygiene cheapness consideration
that I'm staying over a desire to make
me feel welcome and
[Laughter]
comfortable let's keep going there's
plenty more these are a couple of things
that I've been repeatingly sorry
repeatedly among men 35 to 50 that
should have ended up at college should
have ended college graduation curious to
hear if this like too much to ask for or
what else you would ask for I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out